Speaker 1: Speaking of lying, Herschel Walker is
doubling down about his bogus police badge. As a
reminder, Herschel Walker flashed a bogus police
badge during his debate with Raphael Warnock late
last week. Raphael Warnock correctly pointed out.
Herschel Walker has falsely claimed to be a police
officer. Herschel Walker took out a badge. Now,
a badge in and of itself doesn't actually mean
anything. But Herschel Walker continues to focus
on the badge. You have to see this clip. This is
also part of the NBC News interview with Herschel
Walker. He says it's a real badge and the badge
was given to me by a police officer. And then
listen to what Walker claims the badge allows
him to do. This is just beyond belief.
Speaker 2: Let's talk about that moment
at the debate where you flashed the badge.
I don't know if you have the badge with you,
but a lot of people are wondering
who does that badge? Do you?
Speaker 3: That is a badge. Okay.
Speaker 1: It's a legit badge,
he says. Let's continue.
Speaker 3: That's a badge that
I was given by a police officer and.
Speaker 1: Okay, a police officer
gave him the badge.
Speaker 3: I do have you
have it. I carry it with me all the time.
It is a real badge is not a fake bear.
Speaker 1: By the way, at what point does
this become impersonating a police officer?
Speaker 3: They real bad.
Speaker 2: Who gave you the bag?
Speaker 3: This badge is from this band. I
have badges all over the ID, all over Georgia.
Speaker 1: Wait, we're not to believe
that he's an officer all over Georgia.
Speaker 3: Are we even from Chatham County? I
have. Wait, wait. I have. From Chatham County.
Which is the county. Which is the county.
Which is the county from. I have it upside
down. Which is right. Which is the county
from where Senator Warner is from. I have
honorary sheriff badge when that county.
Speaker 1: Oh, it's honorary. Well,
that is meaningless.
Speaker 2: Herschel, where I'm from.
Speaker 3: This is from my hometown. This is from
Johnson County. From the sheriff. Johnson County,
which is a legit badge. Everyone can
make fun, but it is bad humor, too,
right? If I let me finish. If anything
happened in this county, I have the right
to work with the police to getting things done.
Speaker 1: Okay. Did you hear what he just said?
He's using. He's using words. He's the. His
vocal cords are vibrating and producing sound
audible to the human ear. But it doesn't mean
anything. He says the bet the honorary badge
gives him the right. It's interesting
for him to use the word the right when
these right wingers insist. We actually
have very few rights. But now, he says,
an honorary badge gives him the right. You have
the right to. To do what? To work with police.
Work with them in what way? If anything? Anything
like what happens in this county. It doesn't mean
anything. How far does this charade have to
go before Herschel Walker can be charged with
impersonating a police officer and understand
that since the fiasco at the debate last week,
they obviously brought in the entire staff,
presumably to figure out how do we deal with
this? And what they came up with was keep
carrying the badge, keep flashing the badge
and insist that you're like sort of a police
officer. It's absolute and utter insanity.
And this isn't even the most humiliating
badge related event over the last 24 hours